[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what's
on the front pages as they arrive it's
time to see what is making headlines
with Elita Adu and Harry Cole who'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight
all right well let's see what is on some
of those front pages
soon act election is Tori leader and the
next prime minister is the lead for the
I with the headline unite or die sunak
tells Torres
similar sentiments in the express but
adding the words and the liver for our
country
Alisa's paper the guardian also quotes
the new PM's warning to his party that
what is most needed now is unity
the theme of unity or death continues on
the front of the Daily Telegraph
likewise the front of tomorrow's times
as the Metro puts it here comes the
sunac reminding us that he's the
country's first Asian prime minister
according to the mount the new PM Herald
a new dawn for Britain
but the Daily Mirror asks who voted for
you
as you might expect after the recent
Market turmoil the financial times leads
with we should sunax place to get a grip
on the problems of the economy
while City am focuses in on what he has
to do saying now for the difficult part
the Delhi star pictures our third prime
minister this year as October's calendar
boy and asks will he last until the end
of the month
hilarity and use and a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you see on your
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch along with us
now we're joined tonight by the guidance
political correspondent Alita Adu and
the political editor of the sun Harry
Carlita Harry good to have you with us
what a day heard you laughing The Daily
Star front page will probably come to
that a little bit later on but let's
start with the front page of the Metro
if we can let's bring that up and take a
look at it so um look there's a lot for
Mr sunac to do and uh he's saying that
it's just such a privilege that he's
been given this job Alisa I mean what to
do what a month what's a year for us all
um I was just in Parliament speaking to
a number of touring MPS and there seems
to be a sense of calm within the
building but I think that's not the same
as what the public are feeling at the
moment people are feeling very tired
very downtrodden this is the third prime
minister as you said earlier this month
uh the Metro rightly focuses their
Splash on his call for Unity but I mean
this is somebody that was not voted in
has to be known as somebody that was
fighting for his own political career
just seven weeks ago now he is making
history for himself being the first
Hindi prime minister which is great also
the first Asian prime minister but
equally what does that mean really for
Brits and he's got such a large injury I
mean how is he really going to get Unity
with such a cabinet decision division
within his party yeah and all that
division Still Remains doesn't it Harry
I mean did you get that feeling as well
there was a little come it's awesome to
be anticlimactic this afternoon didn't
it like it was kind of I think that you
know the last prime minister I think
managed to get about 24 to 48 hour
honeymoon before obviously the very sad
death of the of the Monarch but also you
know that party remains a Tinderbox just
so yes
we actually see Nick managed to get a
significant number more than half of the
MPS but the other half weren't backing
him they were they scrambled around for
boys Johnson Penny uh penny more than
pretty got got pretty close to forcing
this to a vote I don't think the woes
are over yes you know there is a wing of
the party uh sort of rump of the party
almost that a relieved they've got their
their man in second time lucky
um but they've done that by going
against the wishes of the membership of
going against the you know the kick what
two prime ministers out now you know the
the Mandate is looking wafer thin right
now if if it exists and Richardson
that's really got to come out and speak
tomorrow right there to the nation
because he spent the entire last 96
hours talking to Tory MPS he hasn't said
before today he hadn't said anything in
public for weeks and it just looks like
the old Smoke Filled rooms of of days
gone by where you know a group of 200
people decide who the next leader this
country is he's got to talk to that
Nation tomorrow and explain exactly who
he is what he's going to do and how he's
going to get us out of this place
occurred to me today when he was
speaking I hadn't heard his voice for
quite a long time again let's bring out
the express because that is exactly this
theme about United and that phrase goes
across all the front pages mainly mostly
doesn't it and that's his phrase though
isn't it well no ironically it's
actually the one thing he hasn't said
today is neither he did say we got you
know this is an existential crisis for
the conservative party we're not going
to get another chance there aren't I
mean Larry over there has probably got
more lives in the story party but it's
you know they're on to they're on to
their you know they're really in The
Last Chance Saloon I would say they're
possibly even in the departure Lounge
but he didn't quite say United but he
did say an existential crisis of which
they have to get over yeah and can they
early I mean you alluded to it your
first answer it's going to be really
difficult I mean inflation if that's a
40-year high people are now worried
about their energy bills in April
obviously we've had the chance of scrap
uh future support that you know his
predecessor uh hidden roles in it and
how is somebody who is as rich as he is
I mean he's going to be facing King
Charles Maur who is actually richer then
as much as people
I mean
I think Charles would have a bit of
paper money I mean as much as a lot of
stories to you know try to highlight
that we shouldn't really be focusing on
his wealth there are a lot of people
that feel as they well he is not
representing me I did not back him as
Harry was saying how does he sort of
highlight the fact that he can win a
mandate and that's something that he's
going to have to reckon with
um I mean doubting by his first
statement which is about 90 seconds he
looked very stiff very robotic a bit out
of practice of public speaking as you
asked me he really needs to come to
these steps and you know try and lose
them and turn them as well as you know
sorry membership we're willing to
overlook the the flaws in Liz truss's
offer to them which was they liked what
she was saying they were a bit
uncomfortable about how she was saying
well she's not the you know she'd be the
first to admit she wasn't the most
charismatic and
um
politician when they're speaking Richie
sunx meant to be Mr slick Mr cool he's
so ditched all that and he's trying to
protect play all that down and his
statement launching his campaign
yesterday was a just a little Twitter
graphic with just a black and white text
where he's much prefers being the sort
of salesman and I wonder whether out of
practice I think is a really good way of
putting it whether he is a bruised by
the leadership election which he lost
and actually he's a little bit at Sea
now and you know he's not as we said
earlier he's not going to get a second
chance of this so he really does need to
pull one out the bag tomorrow yeah and
where does it start then I mean the
speech is one thing obviously then you
can have pmqs as well so I mean what are
we expecting to hear from look at the
front page of the uh the eye as well now
that also goes to that United day which
if you told us it's not something he
said today it's not in great marks I
mean the essence is there yes so where
does he start then because I mean look I
think he needs to talk to he does need
to
um talk to people who are worried about
how you know not necessarily paying
their energy bills but paying their
mortgage bills people that can't afford
to buy rent a house people are worried
about their jobs you know there is there
is a you know it is fair to say that all
of these problems are affecting all of
Western uh Financial you know leaders
um all of you know the the inflation is
rampant across the United States across
Europe the energy prices is particularly
exasperated in Europe because of the the
war in Ukraine we get that everyone
understands that that has been hammered
home if anything previous leaders have
been saying that too much without
explaining what they're actually going
to do I mean you've got to level with
the public yes we have these problems
but I think people want to hear what are
the solutions does he have space to to
bring those Solutions a man who was who
was Chancellor who made some tough
decisions himself or feels like he made
some tough decisions I think that there
is a little leeway for him to make some
tough calls going forward I mean
absolutely I mean people are desperate
for him to you know lay out some sort of
solutions I mean we haven't heard from
him during this really short difference
but difficult ones I guess so um we
heard him about seven weeks ago during a
tour leadership race that he lost
initially to his trust and he was saying
that he doesn't want to tell fairy tales
I mean is he going to repeat those sort
of phrases is tomorrow and he released
to outline I think and just try and lay
out his firm stunts yeah I think he's
got to be reality based as well in the
fact that you know yes the previous
prime minister caused problems but there
are already problems coming down the
track we've got a big big announcement
from the bank of England on the 3rd of
November that could potentially see
interest rates mortgage people mortgages
rise even more there has to be a bit of
leveling a bit of reality and the fact
that there's going to this is going to
require some some Public Service cuts at
what those cuts are you know he's going
into the House of Commons to face kirst
armor on Wednesday the first question
Kirsten's going to ask is Right where's
the ACT gonna fall and he needs to have
answers on that and I hope he spent his
instead of licking his wounds in the
last seven weeks I hope he's been
actually thinking about what he'll be
doing differently because he really
hasn't had much time to to make those
decisions yeah let's take a look at the
front page of the Guardian now again
that phrase United will die we're not
going to dwell on on that um but one
thing one season you will have to make
of course is about this National
Insurance rise now of course that was
his big plan wasn't it 12 billion pounds
there's a big hole in the public
finances what are your feelings is there
any chance that we could have a row back
on the non-roadback on that do you think
I mean I think you'd be careful to not
make too many u-turns and try to even I
mean yeah
well I think that people are going to do
I think people are gonna be baffled if
you're saying we're going to raise
National Insurance and we're going to
cut it then we're going to raise it or
then we're going to actually raise the
threshold so you're not paying and
people are just like hang on just you
just said we're going to get income tax
cut six weeks ago and now we're not so
but that's one of the tough decisions
isn't it because that is a lot of money
that he could bring back and it was his
idea it is but I think I mean he was
complicated any sort of mandate he has
this trust you know hid a lot of the
things he wanted to do like the 45p tax
reforms from the Tory membership one
thing she did say she was going to do is
reverse that National Insurance she did
beat him comprehensively with the Tory
membership on that so I would uh I I
would I would hasten he'll probably
avoid touching that third rail
and Elita I mean where then do you think
will the top positions be made by him
I mean
you know
wrapped over things like fracking for
example which had been you know really
heated amongst the party I mean he has
been largely silent and there's issues I
mean we've seen climate change is not
getting any better so we look at the
weather we've just had over the weekend
how's it going to spell issues like that
out you know how is it going to reckon
with the public and tell them that
actually I am the Prime Minister that
will you know improve ambulance waiting
times for example instead of essentially
just blaming a labor who had been in
opposition for the last you know 12
years he can't simply fall back on those
personality politics anymore all right
before we go let's take a look at the
front page of the Daily Mail now as you
can see it describes it as a new dawn
for Britain and it is a I mean you laugh
but it's a huge moment isn't it the
first Hindu prime minister it's a it's a
big and actually what's probably most
remarkable is that we're not finding it
that remarkable that is brilliant the
only reason I took a brief laugh there
was that the Daily Mail has spent the
last six months kicking kicking seven
yeah but
um there we go they've uh they've got
their man now and at least I mean just
the the fact that that it is as they put
a new door for him but just the sort of
the the moment that we're in in history
that yeah
darling and we've got a Hindu prime
minister for the first time I mean I
don't think it's being celebrated enough
sadly and that's because of the turmoil
but let's trust has left uh the state of
you know our country and that's a sad
fact in a way but I mean obviously he is
one of our youngest Prime Ministers
um yeah he's made quite the comeback
yeah it's incredible really interesting
all right Alita Harry thank you very
much for that plenty more to come from
you guys over the break now the pressure
on the incoming prime minister to get a
grip on the economy and we'll have more
on that coming up next
foreign
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview with me is the political editor
of the son Harry Cole and the guardian's
political correspondent Alita I do guys
thanks for staying with us let's have a
look at the front page of the financial
times now of course uh markets have
seemed to have been a bit become by the
fact that Richard sunike is going to be
the next prime minister and and the
times they're saying that sunak is
vowing to get a grip on the economy I
mean can he
ah he's gonna have to he's gonna get his
wiggle on I mean he's got until uh all
well October 31st is when they're meant
to be publishing the forecast of the
figures there's a there was a
provisional draft of that obr forecast
that showed there was a 72 billion pound
black hole gesting some of his trust's
tax cuts has got that down to 30 billion
that leave 40 billion pounds still to
find I suspect 10 billion of pounds of
that might come in some sort of jiggling
of visas and and boosting high schools
immigration uh so that's another 30
billion you've got to find and you know
you're starting to look at big budgets
Defense Education you know where is it
you know where is this stuff going to
come from you know already cut to the
Bone already suffering from inflation uh
hit these budgets already hit by
inflation there ain't much left to cut
so are they going to salami slice off
everywhere or are they going to go for
big cuts in in sort of big big
departments
um obviously that's all incredibly
fraught there's not a majority to tax
pensions it seems there's not a majority
to touch the NHS and uh you might not
you know you might be losing defense
secretaries and ministers if you try to
cut defense at a time of War so big big
questions yeah at least let's get you to
comment on the front page of City am
because I mean they lay out there now
for the difficult part really and and
that is where the difficult would be I
mean we've got a former Chancellor in
the top job a guy who is chancellor now
who seems to have done a pretty fair job
of calming down the market so and we saw
the impact that the markets can have on
the way politics are run
it's quite depressing in a way though
that we're having to look at the markets
again and be like oh actually we've
actually got a prime minister but it's
not you know making things go crazy out
of control and that's really you know
the role of a prime minister but despite
that um I think as you say he's got some
tough decisions to make and it's whether
he's going to be bold enough to put the
right people in the right cabinet
positions whether he's going to be
trying to use different you know sides
of the political parties we're going to
try and keep you know a number of
characters who are larger than life who
are you know more towards the Boris
Johnson era who might not agree with
those tax cuts or is he going to be the
sensible politician that many of his
colleagues are attending him to be that
remains to be seen do you have the
answer yet what do you think
um I mean I still have my colleague over
you know most of the likes of Dominic
Robb being installed as Home Secretary
and that would be quite the move it'd be
another change uh you know in such a
criticism
because yeah it wasn't long ago he was
you know removed from that job for basic
incompetence of the Afghan withdrawal so
a lot of these characters are touted
themselves as you know come back kids
you know they have long histories as
well and I suspect um that will be
pointed out quite quickly yeah and
before we move on to uh our next segment
let's take a look at the Daily Star
because it made you both laugh as we saw
it before uh let's bring this up this is
uh Rishi sunak these calendars are
pretty old school actually sort of
poster calendars generation of a
generational thing I haven't seen
yeah but this is it's quite funny
because uh Rishi is October's man
you know I suspect you know we had a bet
with a colleague of when the tour of the
MPS would start saying they're putting
letters in and uh I think we all agreed
about two weeks